I mean you're dealing with an element
there that hardly anyone ever gets to
see or have anything to do with like
does that excite you oh absolutely I
mean it's uh it's quite surreal to to
get to work with this and there's just
uh so much uh chemistry to do and so
many cool ideas not enough time in the
day to get it done we're updating our
video about element 97 which I call
berum and Americans call berkum because
it was discovered in the US city of
Berkeley we're doing it in quite an
unusual way because Brady was in
Berkeley and he interviewed my former
Nottingham colleague Professor Polly
Arnold who is actually working with
burkum or as she would say now being in
America burkum they make it once every
two years at one of the other National
Labs and we spoke to the program manager
of Department of energy who funds our
big research group here um we had to
basically write him a research proposal
to tell him what we were going to do
with half a milligram and we got it
there's some really interesting
questions about how you can do chemistry
when you have such a tiny amount of an
element less than a milligram if we
wanted to get something like 5
milligrams we would probably spend about
$300,000 when you realize you what a
small amount you're normally going to
get um you immediately think oh cripes
we're never going to be able to make the
confence we propos for this and then
immediately you get together with all
the people because there has to be a
because it's so valuable a few of us
have to get together and decide what
we're going to do because every sample
you get you plan you prepare you
practice you rehearse with other suraga
elements and then you recycle it right
so you have to make something that
you're going to be able to recycle so
that your colleague your friend can use
it again and again and again until its
halflife means that there's none of it
left basically bilian was first really
isolated and studied in
1949 by the famous American chemist Glen
seaborg and it was prepared using a
cyclotron in the Lawrence Berkeley lab
in Berkeley and they chose the name
burkum because if you look at the
periodic table verium comes underneath
turum and their argument was that turum
was named after itabe a town in Sweden
so burkam would be named after Berkeley
a town in California there's been
surprising amount of work done on
studying the chemistry of vum papers
published in 19 70 starts describing the
sort of apparatus they use and how they
can use x-rays to study the structures
of the compounds they make the compound
in the 1970 paper consisted
of a carbon hydrogen C5 H5 ring with the
berium and in fact three of these Rings
round it when you listen to PO Arnold
talking she describes the organic part
around the metal as
Shrubbery Shrubbery is the word we use
in English meaning
bushes some rude people might describe
my hair as
Shrubbery but the idea is that if you
surround an atom with organic lians
organic groups this can allow you to do
more sophisticated chem chemistry
because one burum atom cannot easily
react with another one because they're
kept apart as Polly would say by the
Shrubbery like they're in the little
jail
cells if you
like but they're not like jail cells
because they can move around a bit more
like American footballers who are
protected by all this heavy armor when
they Bang into each other the Berkeley
isotope that we get has a half life of
330 days so basically every week that
we're sitting on it worrying about
whether the reaction is going to work or
not or reprocessing it we're counting
how much we've lost you know we're all
going oh we've only got three quarters
of it left oh too much of it's turning
into California we're going to have no
Berk we don't want to contaminate our
Spectra um and we we well we know that
while it's constantly decomposing or
turning into daughter products um not
only are we giving out a radioactive
dose to everybody but we're losing our
chance to to have enough to grow
crystals and to get beautiful data on
concentrated samples so yeah it's
stressful once the B helium has been
made and we have a nice video showing
the reactor at Oak Ridge where they make
these
elements this is the berkum sample he's
getting out now we had less than a half
a milligram of Berkeley remaining from
our last production campaign Berkeley
and SC a little over a 300 day halflife
so it should be about half of it should
still be remaining in this
sample in the bottom of this glass bile
it comes to a tip and there's a little
bit of green solid material there it's a
burum chloride and after it's been
separated then what happens is that the
people who want to study it have to
write a proposal and there's a big
competition all these different groups I
want my billum and only a few of them
get it and it's judged on the
originality of the scientific ideas they
put forward and it sounds as whatever
Polly has proposed has been very
successful but the paper hasn't yet been
published so we don't know exactly what
what she did I think it must be really
exciting but they know that they've been
successful in their
application months
beforehand and rather than sitting like
you might do to wait for your Christmas
presents they start practicing like mad
because they choose a rare Earth element
that has similar size and chemistry to
the element they're studying in this
case buium and they chose serium as the
standin element if you like and they
keep on practicing doing these
experiments over and over again because
they have to recycle the bikum you do an
experiment and whether it's successful
or not you get the berium back to do it
again I understand this Berkelium sample
arrived at Christmas it was a Christmas
present it was a great Christmas present
yeah yeah so we started working on it in
January which was also extremely
frustrating because because this is a
national lab we have a winter shutdown
that we respect very carefully what was
it like when it arrived was it like a
Christmas present were you all was there
a buzz there there was a huge buzz and
there's also um
um a an incredibly uh frustrating moment
where it arrives um protected from the
people who are transporting it and the
people who are receiving it so it comes
into receiving and then the health and
safety people the health physic assists
have to collect it for us unpackaging
bring it to us and we immediately put it
into its Le leadline box while we get
everything ready to do the reaction I
think it's absolutely fascinating what
they do and I believe although Polly
didn't say this they can handle such
small quantities of material because
it's radioactive so even if you can't
see the material you can use a counter
to trace where it's got to in your
[Music]
apparatus the other thing is that once
you've got crystals of this
compound it the crystal only lasts for a
short time because the energy of the
pelium decaying shatters the crystal
yeah the thing we have to really worry
about is that um because the isotope
we're working with 249 bleum is so
radioactive um it will blow itself apart
so when we grow a single Crystal that we
would put on a defom to look at the
molecular structure we've only got about
3 hours to measure that Crystal on the
defect tometer before one of those um
events has blown it apart I think that
Brady saw the
billum sample but it's really so
small that I don't think any of people
would get excited by this tiny Speck of
material which is probably smaller than
the specks of dirt on my table um it was
tough at the beginning we were pretty
new here as as a research group in
Berkeley as well when it first came um
so one of my people who was working with
it she normally when you start working
with transuranics anything beyond
uranium you would practice on the first
one neptunium and then plutonium um for
which we have a fair amount of they're
still rare and precious um but for her
this was the the first trans ranic she
worked with was Berkeley which is quite
quite incredible given that there's
probably only about a hundred maybe a
couple of hundred people in the world
that have ever seen work clear so quite
an opportunity the really important
question is why on Earth should people
want to study
it and it's not just to show how clever
they are as
chemists though they are pretty clever
to do these
experiments but it is to try and
understand the behavior of the
electrons around these
atoms and these heavy elements like
berium like
californium are good analoges of the
behavior of The Rare Earth elements that
above them in the periodic table and the
reason why they are
important is because their behavior is
more extreme than those of the rare
Earths
and so if you develop a theory to
explain the behavior of the actinides
these heavy elements then that theory
will be much better at explaining the
behavior of The Rare Earth elements the
lanthanides than if you developed your
theory just on the lanides do people
assume that by the time you get to that
point in the bottom of the period table
bottom row um they they always lose the
same number of electrons but there were
hints and suggestions from other work
that we could lose one extra for Berkle
and
we were convinced that by putting some
organic uh plates either side of it to
make a sandwich we could capture and
understand that um that more oxidized
form uh really well and it worked
brilliantly for that it was exactly what
we were hoping to see it's more stable
than we were expeced what sounds as if
was one of the most exciting discoveries
of um poly's group's work was that they
have found a chemical way of separating
californium from berkele the reason why
that's important is because normally you
have a complicated procedure with resins
and so
on and according to what Polly said if I
understood her correctly when they do a
bit of chemistry they get a beautiful
purple
solution the colors of these heavy
elements can often be very beautiful and
they got purple solution and a
precipitate of
californium and they're going to do a
whole lot of chemistry with the
californium
afterwards the californium has a much
longer halflife so they have a bit of
time to work out what they're going to
do but what was very interesting to me
is that the californium
decays in a radioactive way different
from
pelium and so the radiation coming out
of it is much more dangerous it's much
stronger and therefore even though it
lasts longer and therefore the atoms are
decaying at a slower rate it appears to
be much more radioactive these are not
experiments that are done in every
chemistry department but it's really
important for the subject that somebody
should be doing it we've got about a
quarter of a milligram left that's
really sad but we've got more
coming thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video I'll put some links
in the description to other videos we've
made about these exotic elements
including our visit to Oak Ridge and if
you think you'd fancy a career in
chemistry well why not study at the
University of Nottingham where we make
these videos I'll include a link about
that also in the video
description what